wir beginnen mal mit einem thema das mir
persönlich medial viel zu kurz kommt
corona ja depri highlight der woche die
bilder von der querdenker demo in berlin
mannomann diesmal die polizei zwei
wasserwerfer eingesetzt aber nur als
lauer sprühregen schon daran erkennt man
die sogenannte korona diktatur ist halt
doch nur einbildung wahrscheinlich eine
nebenwirkung von den vielen globuli und
natürlich wurde wieder ohne masken
demonstriert ohne abstand im kampf für
das berühmte grundrecht jederzeit andere
menschen anstecken zu dürfen
querdenker sind eben patrioten nur warum
vergewaltigen sie dann meine hymne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
viele ältere berliner dachten es ist
wieder fliegeralarm und sind direkt in
den luftschutzkeller demonstriert wurde
gegen das neue infektionsschutzgesetz
oder wie die verstrahlten und die
rechten es nennen das
ermächtigungsgesetz seit wann haben
nazis was gegen ermächtigungsgesetz vor
allem die doch immer gut querdenker
haben im bundestag abgeordnete
angepöbelt eingeladen von der afd
soviel zu dieser demokratischen parteien
meine klar kann man kritik üben am neuen
infektionsschutz zum beispiel hätte die
rolle des parlaments noch deutlich
stärker ausfallen können trotzdem ist
diese woche doch wirklich der ultimative
beweis dass wir in keiner merkel
diktatur leben die ministerpräsidenten
mucken auf haben sie bestimmt
mitgekriegt es gab eine offene revolte
gegen die kanzlerin eine diktatur
am montag diskutiert die bund länder
runde fünf stunden lang und verkündet
dann als einziges ergebnis
wir treffen uns nächste woche wieder
willkommen im kindergarten
die bundeskanzlerin ist richtig sauer
weil das in den bundesländern eben nicht
klappt aber die ministerpräsidenten
wiederum die sind auch sauer und zwar
auf die bundeskanzlerin untereinander
gibt es auch noch streit alle gemeinsam
sind ziemlich sauer auf berlin
die angel aber angefangen gar nicht wohl
anhaltend hohe infektionszahlen und man
streitet über verfahrensfragen ganz
tolles signal wenn er so verlieren wir
noch mal wertvolle zeit ist ja so
nächsten mittwoch wollen sie angeblich
den langfristigen corona masterplan
verkünden
da es seien nur noch einfallen muss ich
meine diese woche gab es also keine
neuen maßnahmen und dafür nur appelle
wobei die meisten von denen durchaus
sinn machen zum beispiel der appell
vermeiden sie unnötige reisen in
risikogebiete wie spanien da ist
durchaus was dran
wir haben das exponentielle wachstum auf
zu hohem niveau vorläufig gestoppt heißt
es aber das virus bleibt natürlich
verdammt türkisch viele infektionen so
haben ist mir meine wissenschaftlichen
bereich
der kürzlich gesagt finden durch kleine
unschuldige die arme
gebärdendolmetscherin so was werden sie
nächsten mittwoch verkünden kann ich
direkt mars boylan man nennt mich nicht
umsonst oliver welke verkündet werden
achtung neue kontakt beschränkungen
woher weiß ich das weil ihnen nie was
anderes einfällt
meine wohlgemerkt an weniger kontakten
geht natürlich kein weg vorbei aber man
bräuchte trotzdem mal zusätzliche
frische ideen nehmen wir nur mal die
sogenannte korona war gut das ist zu
hart fakt ist aber man hat trotz ihrer
schwächen seit juni nicht wirklich
weiterentwickelt in ein paar wochen soll
sie vielleicht in der lage sein cluster
zu erkennen nehmt euch alle zeit der
welt demnächst kriegen risikogruppen
endlich verbilligte ffb zwei masken
warum nicht sofort und warum nicht
umsonst die slowakei südtirol und madrid
machen derweil super erfahrungen mit
massentests und wir wenn es blöd läuft
hangeln wir uns bis april von einem lock
down zum nächsten
ich fürchte es hat wahrscheinlich sogar
revolutionäre auswirkungen auf den homo
sapiens dass wir jetzt dauerhaft
höhlenbewohner werden erstmal wird durch
das ewige gesetze natürlich unser steiß
breiter dann verfetten wir insgesamt
durch das ständige vor der glotze hängen
und bringen dienst bit zerfressen
die augen werden größer und schlechter
die finger werden extrem lang und besser
in die pringles dose zu kommen und weil
man als single keinen mehr kennen lernt
fällt irgendwann der penis ab darf ich
vorstellen
der hohe lockt orients is sexy
obwohl ich muss mich direkt korrigieren
einen kreativen einfall hatte unsere
kanzlerin tatsächlich kinder sollen sich
zitat nur noch mit einem festen freund
oder einer festen freundin treffen
da stellen sich natürlich fragen muss
mein kind wirklich jeden tag einen neuen
freund treffen zum spielen oder zum
zusammenkommen oder kann man das auf
einen besten freund eine beste freundin
beschränken
und was machen die leute wie ich habe
überhaupt keine feste freunde vollkommen
wirklichkeitsfremde unsinn aber wenn
sich das durch
selbst freunde müssen unter anderem
sämtliche kinder bücher umgeschrieben
werden
die drei fragezeichen sind dann klar die
zwei fragezeichen justus jonas ist raus
der blöde klugscheißer tkkg ist nur noch
tk und es trifft natürlich auch disney
klassiker wie schneewittchen und der
eine zwerg da jetzt ihr fester freund
ist von pippi langstrumpf einmal ganz zu
schweigen
du bist raus annika ich habe mich für
tami entschieden die opfer
niemand mag annika und wo wir gerade bei
kinder problemen sind komplett vertagt
hat die bund länder darunter auch das
ganze thema schule
das robert koch institut fordert zwar
seit wochen geteilte klassen in
risikogebieten aber kommt dürften
bereich doch völlig hat sich bewährt im
grunde welche rolle schule als pandemie
treiber genau spielt darüber streiten
die experten noch
tatsächlich haben sich aber viel mehr
kinder und jugendliche infiziert als
bisher gedacht die sind meist symptomlos
und trotzdem anstecken ist das blöde ich
glaube ja einige kultusminister
klar man sie auch deshalb so an den
präsenzunterricht damit keiner merkt wie
gnadenlos wir bei der digitalisierung
der schulen immer noch hinterher hängen
es ist ja so sind können nicht einfach
sagen wir machen jetzt mal halbe klassen
sie brauchen dann im grunde genommen
fast das doppelte an lehrerinnen und
lehrer die wir nicht haben nein sie
brauchen sich ideal war anstoß ist
gerade im klassenzimmer es anders nach
real existierende ganzen film
nein nein doch doch doch es ist schon
richtig digital unterricht wirft vor
allem sozial schwächere kinder weiter
zurück helfen könnte aber die hybride
lösung der lehrer unterrichtet eine
hälfte in der klasse und wird dabei per
webcam in die kinderzimmer der schüler
zu hause übertragen so eine kamera mit
mikro kostet york knapp 12 euro
zum vergleich die autoindustrie hat
diese woche noch mal fünf milliarden
geschenk bekommen schul und corona reden
wir drüber mit einem prominenten opfer
des deutschen bildungssystems mit olaf
schubert wohl auch schön dass du da bist
ja sind so auch die politik will offene
schulen und präsenzunterricht so lange
wie möglich wie stehst du dazu
ich würde die schulen für mindestens
zwei wochen schließen
ja aber natürlich erst wenn alle schüler
drinnen sind es ist er natürlich
bewiesen ja dass das das kind ja den
normalen tagesablauf stört da gibt es
studien die stimmen denn die sind von
mir und wenn die schulen offen bleiben
sollen müssen wir sie einfach wirklich
mehr unterstützen
ja ich meine die bundeswehr hilft ja
momentan überall also warum nicht auch
in der schule natürlich nicht in allen
klassen aber wenigstens in den unteren
ja es gibt ja den unteroffizier dann
heißt eben nicht mehr still gestanden
sondern stelle gesessen und es ist ja
ganz wichtig dass der wille des kindes
ganz früh gebrochen wird und ich denke
in zwei wochen tritt könnten da fiel
wieder geraderücken und was ich halb in
den letzten jahren falsch gemacht haben
jetzt gibt es eine pisa sondererhebung
zur digitalisierung an schulen da lange
deutschland in der schlussgruppe da sind
nicht so überraschend noch hinter
moldawien woran liegt das
also moldawien ich sag mal so ich glaube
ich weiß sie haben vielleicht zwei
millionen einwohner davon 17 schüler ich
mir da genügt ein laptop und das ganze
land ist digital
deutschland hat ja eine ganz andere
pädagogische tradition so nenne ich mal
also als digital unterricht gilt ja in
deutschland wenn der lehrer ein gedicht
über ein usb-kabel vorliest oder wenn
die schüler in einen taschenrechner
zeichnen ja also in einigen schulen ist
wirklich sogar der rechenschieber und
noch fortschritt ich denke der
digitalisierung schub kommt durch die
lehrer ja also nämlich dann wenn die
lehrer von den schülern erfahren haben
welche erotik portal kostenlos sind ich
habe es eben angesprochen die gefahr
dass durch digital unterricht und
homeschooling sozial schwache und
lernschwache kinder noch weiter
zurückfahren wie groß ist das problem
da steckt ja die die stigmatisierung
schon im begriff lernschwach ja blöd
dass sie so einmal kevin immer kevin ich
meine ersetzen wir es statt lernschwach
erkenntnis resistent das ging dafür
robuste ja ich meine man muss nicht
immer die die hellste kerze auf dem
backwerk sein um der heutigen zeit
folgen zu können also im gegenteil ich
sag mal wenn man manche influenza oder
youtube stars verstehen will da ist
bildung und intellekt völlig
kontraproduktiv also da muss ein
umdenken stattfinden und so ist sie auch
in der wirtschaft sicherlich wir
brauchen ein paar streber und superhirn
hengste die den ganzen technischen
apparat entwickeln aber wir brauchen
auch menschen mit einer gewissen
schlichtheit im gemüt die das zeug dann
auch kaufen und anwenden es müssen nicht
alle studieren ja wenn es heißt
jüdischer rom schreibt und der neunten
klasse sein vorname mit sch aber die
muss man machen ist ja hochbegabt also
so wird es nichts was ist das geheimnis
von gutem homeschooling gehörst du dich
bei deinen kindern da eingebracht das
hauptproblem sind natürlich die
unterschiedlichen leistungsniveaus ja
also ist es wert ist weiß ich auch aus
gesprächen mit freunden es gibt ja
wirklich kinder die sind ja nicht mal in
der lage den eltern vor beginn des
homescreens eine flasche bier
aufzumachen
ja also dann wird der unterricht
natürlich trocken und man muss den
lehrplan entschlacken also ich hab so
einige fächer zusammengelegt zum
beispiel mathematik und religion ja also
das kind rechnet was aus und glaubt dass
es stimmt oder dann eben für atheisten
hatte und philosophie schoppenhauer man
rechnet mit dem schlimmsten
das macht nicht immer spaß aber da muss
man durch du kannst das kind ja nicht
wie so ein haustier einfach an der
tankstelle aussetzen
also ich hab's probiert aber klappt
nicht die sind so clever den trampen
zurück ärgerlich olaf schubert
[Musik]
was ich über meinen arsch geigensolo war
doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]